buongiorno a tutti
non prendete paura è oggi vi parlo
proprio di questa maschera questa per
chi non la conosce è una maschera che
viene usata nel teatro nero quando si
vuole creare un personaggio inanimato un
personaggio privo di emozioni un
personaggio neutro
vi chiederete cosa c'entra con la
disabilità questo è a mio avviso invece
è il tema centrale questo vedete molte
persone la maggior parte che non
conoscono questa realtà si immaginano
una realtà piena di dolore piena di
sofferenza che a volte fa paura e da cui
è meglio stare lontani è meglio non
vedere
ed è questo l'errore che il più delle
volte facciamo noi pensiamo invece di
guardare dietro questo noi pensiamo e
questo ce lo insegna che questa maschera
non l'ha mai avuta e sono loro che ci
insegnano far cadere la nostra di
maschera perché senza saperlo ce
l'abbiamo noi
vedete cose banali e scontate che
facciamo tutti i giorni ma proprio
perché scontato e banale
roma noi non diamo più valore loro sì
loro gli danno molto valore proviamo un
attimo pensare a una cosa molto semplice
che usiamo tutti i giorni lo sguardo
avete mai pensato quante cose possiamo
dire con lo sguardo e invece non lo
usiamo facciamo una piccola cosa assieme
provate a girarvi e salutare che vi
avete accanto e vi pregherei di farlo
ora lo facciamo in un altro modo prima
vi girate
guardate negli occhi la persona che
avete accanto e poi gli dite ciao
e stato diverso vero e sapete perché
perché prima avete salutato un estraneo
ora guardandovi negli occhi se siete
riusciti naturalmente a guardarvi bene
negli occhi prima avete scoperto che
quella persona ha dentro qualcosa così
come ce l'avete voi
e chiaro che guardare fa paura perché
guardare ci denuda dentro ma questi
occhi che avete visto passare questi non
hanno paura di guardare e questi sono
gli sguardi che io e chi come me lavora
in questo mondo riceve tutti i giorni e
sono sguardi sinceri e profondi e
valgono molto più di mille parole
guardate queste immagini le mani
avete mai pensato alle mani no perché le
mani sono talmente un attrezzo del
nostro corpo
servono per fare per lavorare per
prendere e comunicare le mani ci
accolgono le mani sono il primo contatto
che noi abbiamo da quando nasce un amore
ci dicono vieni ci portano dentro questo
mondo e non hanno paura di toccare non
hanno paura di farsi toccare ora usiamo
un attimo quello sguardo di prima solo
per osservare queste mani
a volte non servono parole a volte basta
imparare a guardare e guardando le paure
cadono qui non c'è paura di far cadere
emozioni di nasconderle e queste
immagini dovrebbero insegnarci qualcosa
dovrebbero insegnarci che a volte le
parole ma non lasciate qua è tutto il
resto bisogna usarlo con gli occhi
con i sensi queste mani lavorano in modo
diverso dal nostro
perché toccano toccano in maniera curata
osservando fieri di quello che stanno
facendo non è frettoloso non è tanto per
fare quello che facciamo noi tutti i
giorni invece impariamo da queste
immagini
ora tutto questo che ti ho raccontato e
che spero abbiate un po cercato di
provare e di capire magari se tenete la
mano di chi vi sta accanto
provate anche voi a sentire cosa il
contatto ma sentitelo realmente senza
guardar vi sentite solo la vostra pelle
tutto questo sfocia sempre in qualcosa
in qualcosa di bello che spesso ci
vergogniamo a fare specie qualcosa di
profondo di vero e di reale sfocia in un
abbraccio
io non vi chiedo di farlo però se
qualcuno vuole iniziare a togliere
questa maschera abbracciarsi e
bellissimo
togliamo la maschera che portiamo tutti
i giorni sotto non ci sono dei mostri ma
ci siamo tutti noi
grazie